when I went to Dollywood and when I was
studying you so much in my 20s and I you
know grew up with you and I started like
you have a passage here about how much
you loved Johnny Carson oh I did love
him that was the very first talk show I
did at 7 years old in
1982 so I mean even though I'm a little
bit younger like we did travel same
Circle similar times why did you love
Johnny Carson so much well I just
thought I just loved how he was I
thought he was funny but I thought he
was basically shy and I know we would
talk a lot in between commercials yes
and and uh I really felt like we got to
know each other and it makes a
difference when people talk to in
commercials and I noticed when they
didn't and I wasn't offended by it but I
just thought oh they're that kind of
person they're they're doing their job
to me it all Blends in it's all messy
but Johnny was just great he was a great
guy and he was funny and he was sweet
and I just liked him he he was very
generous he was very kind to me cuzz I
was very country at the time and that's
when I was just beginning to go around
to the big city people and do all that
and he sensed that somehow and so he
always tried to make me feel more
comfortable and play with me in a way
like a you know like someone just trying
to make me more at ease that's exactly
how I felt cuz I was seven years old and
I took out my teeth and I put them on
his desk because I I didn't take my
teeth out
for
you know maybe you would have had you
know I I've been watching you since you
were tiny so you had fake teeth to when
you did the movies right when your teeth
came out yeah when I was a baby and I
was losing teeth I'm sure I'll be in
false teeth again it'll all come full
circle well you don't have to tell
everything yeah though that's true do
don't I I can't help it you tell
everything you seem like a very
openhearted open but we all have our our
personal little secrets I'm I'm very
private person to be honest even though
I'm very open to the public and I'm very
honest if you ask me a question I'll
tell you the truth and I know who I am
uh what I I know what I know and I know
what I don't know I know what I will do
what I won't do what I should do what I
shouldn't do and I just have that
built-in monitor inside myself did you
always have that did it grow and evolve
over time well everything grows and
evolves you develop even in my music or
you know even in just as a person that's
why they say wisdom comes with age and
if that's true I ought to be really
smart about now I think you are always
smart you say things in a way that is so
who you are and what you believe and yet
you say it in a way that includes
everybody else well I love everybody I
always know that there's that little God
light that little thing in every human
being and I try to go to that because I
know that nobody would be the way they
are if they could be different you know
it's like I wrote a song called whatever
you are be that whatever you do do that
cuz anything else is just an act so
whoever you are be that and I I just I'm
not a good enough person or good enough
Christian to judge and criticize other
people I want to be loved and accepted
so the least I can do is to try to love
and accept other people and I love the
difference in people just like that
spice the variety of life being you
know I mean if everybody was the same
what you know it would be a boring life
wouldn't
[Music]
it